so mid-2000s mobile money
changes finance forever in africa and
other places
so what is mobile money so you take a
continent that
very few atms people don't have access
to banks
no access to finance all of a sudden
they can access the financial system
through their phone
and it's even simpler it's through their
sim card so what that means is i can sit
in new york wherever i sit send money to
someone's phone
in a refugee settlement in uganda they
get a text
they see you've received a hundred
dollars in this case
shillings great whenever they want they
can take that phone to a local agent
and convert that money either to digital
cash sorry either to physical cash and
take it out like you would take out
money from an atm
or buy stuff with it so oh my goodness
now i can access all these people
that i couldn't access before with the
technology we know people aren't just
going to start drinking and quitting
their jobs
let's get on a plane and see if there's
anything else we're missing and that's
what we did
went to kenya the first person was one
of my co-founders rohit
started walking around asking people for
their phone numbers
wow i love it so much so then they were
like who are these
uh oddballs asking us for our phone
numbers but i guess they're trusting and
they they're like what i'm gonna do i'll
i'll give it to you you'd be surprised
i mean imagine if i knocked on your door
and said hey andrew
i'm here never met me just sign some
forms give me your phone number and i'll
give you twenty thousand dollars
well this is a very important lesson uh
and it's something that i've learned
uh in different contexts but it's really
tricky to give people money
you think that it's easy but then you
have to be like okay
i know in stockton um
michael tubbs had to reach out to people
multiple times because they just
wouldn't believe it um
for me when i was running for president
and we decided to give people
a thousand dollars a month for a year
uh there were all these rules around it
where and i was like wait a minute let
me let me get this straight
i can spend millions of dollars on
advertising no problem i can
pay a consultant millions or you know
hopefully you don't pay i can sell
millions but
i consulted like you know like like six
figures
no problem i want to give an american a
thousand
dollars a month it's like no no no i
can't do that i can't do that
welcome back to yang speaks uh we have
an incredible
interview today with michael fay the
co-founder and ceo of give directly he's
given a lot of people
money very directly but before that
we have a really exciting announcement
my new book forward will be coming out
on october 5th and you can pre-order it
right now
i am so amped about this book it's going
to be the next chapter
of my life because
in true andrew egg fashion i couldn't
just write a book and then be like and
there's a book it's like
and now let's go do the thing so what
thing are we talking about
you have to read the book to find out
but it goes through
my experiences and what i learned on the
presidential trail
it goes through some of the things i
learned about our political system
the media the way technology interacts
with the media
and then it sets out a path forward and
how we can actually solve these problems
and i'm going to be doing my best to
help solve them
uh but i hope you are amped for this
book i'm really proud of it really
excited about it you can buy it right
now
you can order the book anywhere uh your
favorite bookseller
uh does the thing amazon's there barnes
like any of the
in any of your favorite book sellers you
can just pre-order the book and then if
you pre-order the book it's
gonna show up magically on that sale
date
uh so you know you can send it and
forget it
uh yeah uh be obviously very very
grateful to everyone for
buying the book uh and i think you're
gonna love it i'm really excited about
it
not many people have read it but the
people that have read it have had
a awesome things to say which has made
me really happy i'm excited about this
book for two reasons andrew one
um you know i read your last book and i
quit my job on wall street to go
run your campaign so um i say this
knowing all and it started a national
movement and made you who you are right
now
um but i would argue there's this book
is
better and more important um it's more
it gets
and you've said this before like every
book you write kind of gets more and
more closer to the bone
and i think this does that um which is a
crazy statement given the impact the
last one
um but the second thing i'm curious
thoughts on this as you start
to kind of slowly launch this book is
i feel like when you're running for
office you're in like a bit of
a you can't be truly authentic i know
you always want to be but you're trying
not you're trying to like navigate
like thread the needle or walk that fine
line i'm excited for like uncaged andrew
yang going forward i feel like the book
is a very honest
reflection of both the presidential
candidate and what we actually need to
do to solve problems do you agree with
that are you excited about that am i or
am i just
doing this alone here i'm excited about
that for sure man i mean i i tried to
give
uh like a bird's-eye view or an uh
candidate's view uh as to what it was
like for me running
what i learned uh i mean you and i joked
about it all the time
um uh when we're on the trail where
people understood what this process was
it's so i want people to understand it
i want people to understand what we
actually need to do to move the country
forward
it's a little different than what we're
being sold all the time or a lot
different
like we're being sold a lot of stuff
that actually would not make the
difference
uh and i've figured out what the real
difference makers are
and they're doable it's it's achievable
you know the last book the more on
normal people i think it
awakened people to the fact that
something like universal basic income is
both necessary
and achievable and i feel like in some
ways this is a direct
sequel in that the problem
was not precisely what i thought it was
the problem
i i tried to solve for was that not
enough people knew about universal basic
income
and if we could get enough people behind
it then we could uh pass it
and now i think the problem is that our
government does not actually
listen to us
[Laughter]
or uh respond to us in the way that
we're taught
um as children in this country
um and so how do we change that yeah
it's uh and
exactly kind of what was saying for that
that's a deeper cut
right um because you got people a cash
leaf is favorable
um both in democratic party and
nationally but we still don't
we have only parts of it right and
there's plenty of other issues we're all
aligned on and we don't actually solve
for and there's a lot of systemic
the the question i set out dancer is
that like the first line of the book is
like why isn't it working
uh you know like that's what we're all
trying to figure out and i think i
figured out at least
a big part of it so please do
get excited book comes out october 5th
but you can order your copy right now
i'm going to do everything i can to
start publishing
excerpts and like little bits and pieces
but
a lot of it's gonna have to wait until
october um so
excited about it really proud of it i
think this may be
the greatest contribution that i make uh
so
you know i might feel like the last book
in cash relief
enormous contributions but i think this
may be as big or bigger
with that make sure you get your copy
because those are bold
those are big words from andrew yang
i'm excited forward by andrew yang go
get one
[Music]
today's episode of yang speaks is
brought to you by better help
folks it is time if you haven't yet to
start
focusing and taking charge of your
mental health things that are
interfering with your happiness things
that are
keeping you from being your highest
functioning self personally i've done
better help
i've started talking to someone once a
week and it is
fantastic you go on betterhelp's website
you can start communicating under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help per se it's just professional
counseling done securely
online you can send a message to your
counselor at any time it's all booked
online when you're talking about stress
and anxiety and relationships and
sleeping and grief or self-esteem
professional advice all of it completely
confidential convenient and professional
and affordable so here's the deal i want
you to start living a happier life today
and as a listener of yank speaks you're
going to get 10 off your first month
by visiting our sponsor betterhelp.com
yang so join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelphelp.com
don't miss it i am so pumped to welcome
to the podcast one of my personal heroes
and role models
the man who has made giving people money
real for millions of people around the
world
the co-founder and ceo of give directly
and tap tap send michael fay
michael welcome to oh you're way too
kind andrew i'm stoked to be here
yes so you you're like a real-life
superhero
and someone that i call occasionally to
learn from
um because when i ran for president on
universal basic income
it was abstract to a lot of people and
one of the things i say to people all
the time was that
that and this wasn't me this was a
neuroscientist who said to me andrew
what you're going to be combating is
uh is the human mind when you start
talking about trying to give everyone
money
uh because we're all programmed for
resource scarcity
and you're someone who has demonstrated
that this works so how the heck did you
come to
cash relief uh and then how did you get
your start because
you were something unusual you were a
grad student who then uh
went out and started an organization on
the side
but how did that come about yeah it's a
funny state of the world when giving
people money
to make them less poor is considered
innovative right well
yeah but i mean again you've
demonstrated that it works
uh so give directly got started a number
of years ago and then i think it got
more public attention
um more recently um let's let's take it
all the way back because people might be
interested
uh like did you have a childhood
interest in giving people money
[Laughter]
i've asked my parents that so many times
i can't remember
look i think we i did a i worked at the
un for two years
i worked for jeff sacks in the
millennium project i went to get a phd
in economics
and study development economics so so uh
so step back um you grew up here in the
states i grew up in the states i was
born in brooklyn grew up in long island
oh it is to public school teacher
parents yes
oh wow and so um so how the heck did you
wind up working uh for the uni i guess
as a new york product that might have
been a natural aspiration
as i went i went to school i met jeff
sax
uh started doing international work
there i actually hadn't left the country
i think until i was late high school
early college and where was that the
first trip was to australia and the
second one is to costa rica
but the one that changed a lot was to
ecuador it was the year that ecuador
dollarized
and there was just extraordinary poverty
during that process
wow what year was that oh gosh you're
testing my memory which isn't great
ecuador was 2004 about i'm sorry
2 000. wow so you go to ecuador in 2000
uh you're working for the u.n and then
you go back to school and i i guess your
exposure to uh poverty
in a very deep sense then influenced
your studies
yeah so i decided that's what i was
going to focus on the first organization
i started was something called the
student global aids campaign
with a number of other people and that
was focused on getting aids relief
and drugs to those in most need
started to work with jeff on some
research projects went with him down to
the un
and decided that's what i was going to
spend my time on
so a lot of people have thought about
giving people money how did you get
actually into the giving people money
business and it's not a business in your
case it's been non-profits
well people had been giving people money
we weren't the first to give people
money to make them less poor there were
ngos there were governments doing it
um what we did was to do it exclusively
and really start to talk about taking it
to scale which asks
which begs the question of why hadn't it
been taken to scale before
so when you say exclusively you mean
exclusive to your organization or that's
the only intervention
that's the only thing we do and we're
focused on it and i looked back and
there was a conversation because we
couldn't understand this so we were grad
students
we were studying development and at the
time there were a number of evaluations
coming out
that showed when you give people money
they spend it well
and they spend it frankly better than a
lot of organizations spend it and what
year was that
oh gosh so i started graduate school in
what 2004.
all right so so the mid-2000s there are
studies coming out that are saying hey
giving people money uh works um and so
you get excited about that and uh some
other
grad students get excited it's more than
that and this was the revolution so
i think two years ago the nobel prize
went to esther to flow
michael kramer and abigail banergy for
bringing the tools
of evaluation and randomized trials to
the stubby
study of poverty alleviation right so
these are tools you use in
tech companies to test what color button
should we use
it's what we use to test drugs and
vaccines but it had not been tested
on these other life-saving interventions
of poverty reduction
so we test this is happening early 2000s
we learned two things one giving people
money works
well and and this is a time
when the customary intervention was not
necessarily to give people money i
remember
that there was a lot of stuff around
nets textbooks laptops
well nets absolutely work there's a lot
of stuff that doesn't work
this was also the time of the micro
finance revolution so you heard it here
first
money works nets work it's like
wormy works there are things that work
we spend a lot of money on other things
that don't work
and that's what we've got to fix i mean
money works
pretty clearly and so you saw the data
and
and thought okay like we should do more
of this so
uh how did a group of scrappy grad
students then
end up uh getting the resources to
to start training because i i think
there was something really uh
grassroots-y and
and uh inspirational about it where you
just started with very very small sums
of money is that right
oh yeah and we used to have this auction
each year for the department of where to
give money to and
at some point you spend enough years
studying poverty some friends start to
ask
where should i donate it's like oh
that's a good question i've been reading
too many textbooks i don't have a great
answer for you
let me actually think about this for a
bit so actually why can't we just give
directly to people so that seems to make
sense we see the evidence now
next step let's find an organization to
do that and we called a number of
organizations some of whom had run
pilot programs and said can we just give
you money
to give directly well that's going to be
complicated well why is it going to be
complicated
um it became clear that no one was going
to do it for us
so interesting so the mid-2000s you look
up and say okay uh where can we donate
money so it'll be directly transferred
to
people who are struggling in poverty in
the developing world and then uh you
can't find it
so then you decide to start that org
yourself
there were a few steps in the process
step one was we must be missing
something
we're naive kids that have been studying
economic economic models
what are we missing there's a reality
aspect to all of this
now fortunately there's another big
change at the time right it wasn't just
the research
so mid-2000s mobile money
changes finance forever in africa and
other places
so what is mobile money so you take a
continent that
very few atms people don't have access
to banks
no access to finance all of a sudden
they can access the financial system
through their phone
and it's even simpler it's through their
sim card so what that means is i can sit
in new york wherever i sit send money to
someone's phone
in a refugee settlement in uganda they
get a text
they see you've received a hundred
dollars in this case
shillings great whenever they want they
can take that phone to a local agent
and convert that money either to digital
cash sorry either to physical cash and
take it out like you would take out
money from an atm
or buy stuff with it so oh my goodness
now i can access all these people
that i couldn't access before with the
technology we know people aren't just
going to start drinking and quitting
their jobs
let's get on a plane and see if there's
anything else we're missing and that's
what we did
went to kenya the first person was one
of my co-founders rohit
started walking around asking people for
their phone numbers
wow i love it so much so then they were
like who are these
uh oddballs asking us for our phone
numbers but i guess they're trusting and
[Laughter]
they they they're like what are you
gonna do i'll i'll give it to you you'd
be surprised
i mean imagine if i knocked on your door
and said hey andrew
i'm here never met me just sign some
forms give me your phone number and i'll
give you twenty thousand dollars
well this is a very important lesson uh
and it's something that i've learned
in different contexts but it's really
tricky to give people money
you think that it's easy but then you
have to be like okay
i know in stockton um
michael tubbs had to reach out to people
multiple times because they just
wouldn't believe it
um for me when i was running for
president and we decided to give people
a thousand dollars a month for a year
uh there were all these rules around it
where and i was like wait a minute let
me let me get this straight i can spend
millions of dollars on advertising no
problem
i can pay a consultant millions or you
know hopefully you don't pay i can sell
millions but
i consulted like you know like like six
figures
no problem i want to give an american
a thousand dollars a month it's like no
no no i can't do that i can't do that
um and so when we did it first you have
to try and identify people you have to
convince them that it's above board
and then there's a there was a process
at least here domestically as a
candidate
so we found that the easiest way for uh
us to give
someone a thousand bucks a month was for
me personally to give them a thousand
dollars a month
because that's below the irs gift limit
which is above twelve thousand dollars
uh and i was like wait let me get this
straight
like the easiest way for us to do this
is for me the candidate
just to give people a thousand bucks a
month and
uh and so i was literally writing
personal checks uh and i like just dated
them for the first of the month and just
like sent people
in part because i wasn't going to
remember to venmo them
like in the first of every month like
probably i was like look let me just
again and they'll also know it's real
because they'll have checks in an
envelope
um so it's uh i'd imagine the
it's both easier and harder to get this
done um
in the developing world context because
there are probably no rules against it
right like i can give someone you'd be
surprised
okay yeah so let's let's so yeah what
were your findings the
complexity of giving people money is
vastly underestimated
agreed because it raises a lot of
questions that we should have been
asking for a long time and everything
else
so what happens when you say well you're
just gonna give a lot of people money
they say well how do you know it's the
right people great question
that's called targeting in the
literature but it applies to everything
if i was giving people sheep how do you
know it's the right people you would
definitely need to make sure
you were giving a sheep to the right
person if you gave the wrong person a
sheep
[Laughter]
the biggest would go poorly for both the
sheep and uh
you know maybe the person yeah we uh i
didn't bring a sheep for you today i'm
sorry andrew
that's totally fine i would have been
one of the wrong people
so you've got the targeting problem
right so that's problem one
second problem people say well how do
you know there's not fraud
if you're giving people money surely
people are going to try to steal it
and the answer is they do and you have
to build systems for that
but you know what that's true of every
development program and every social
program
and one of my favorite answers to that
is yeah but cash is really valuable
wait a second so we're going to say
we're going to give people things that
are not valuable
lest other people try to defraud the
system that logic doesn't make sense so
how do you deal with fraud
how do you make sure you're not causing
issues in the community
of any sort right you don't want to be
invoking domestic violence as it turns
out cash reduces domestic violence yes
you want to make sure that you're not
altering power you have to be very
thoughtful about that
and then you have to be very aware of
both local and national political
structures
like people get worried are you giving
to one ethnic group over another
are you trying to affect the next
election and those are the things
we do not try to affect the next
elections um
that's the difference between you and me
by going up so so
uh well cash is very popular uh from a
government standpoint
i mean a majority of people are for it
uh uh here in america and now
happily uh when i got started the the uh
approval rate for universal basic income
was i think something like 24 percent it
was not high
and now it's last i checked it was uh
like 56 percent
um so i think it's incredible what's
happening over the last two years and
you obviously played a central role in
that but i think people's perception
well you played a central role in
helping me know that it's real and
actionable um so uh so rohit shows up in
kenya
uh in the mid-2000s and starts gathering
phone numbers
and then he comes back and he's like
okay guys i got some phone numbers like
you know
like so so then you uh raised some money
and started sending it to people like
well i i i repeated the endeavor uh
shortly thereafter so you went too and
you're like we need more phone numbers
it's my turn
yeah and i'm very distinctly walking
around the camp asking people for their
number
a lot of people saying no are you part
of the illuminati no one's
ever given me something for free what
are you going to ask me for i just don't
trust you
you spend a lot of time and we did that
one of my favorite um
memories of that trip was there was a
little store outside
the uh outside the area and it was empty
it was completely abandoned
and you can imagine going in and saying
well what are we going to give people
cash for
there's nothing to buy here there's no
market there's no stores
you gave people money guess what the
store started to fill up
because it made sense for the shopkeeper
to go back to buy inventory and start
selling things
and that you see in the research since
which is you actually
not only have an impact on the people
that get cash
but on those that don't get cash and the
broader economy
yeah and there's a very important point
there which is that
that the the market will seek out people
that have the resources
uh if you're not able to participate in
the market then you go to the town
you're like well there's nothing going
on here but
if all of a sudden the people in that
town had money then
uh there would be a like a business that
that's serving them
um or they'd start it themselves because
they look up and say wait a minute you
know it's like
we we need to we need to shop here and
like i can do that and then it starts
it's like a basic food stand and
everything else
markets respond and they respond quickly
and surely there are places where that
may not be the case because you're so
far off the grid i mean it's working
you know it's working it's kind of
working i mean we're doing this in
liberia
yeah you can do it in very tough places
and liberia doesn't even print their own
money
they have to get it brought in on boats
um there was really no mobile money
infrastructure in liberia when we got
started
there's a rainy season which cuts off
large parts of the country
so what happened now how many countries
have you been to 11 countries
11 countries that's so fun um so so you
and
and the band of grad students then
started sending small sums uh
to two people what was like the total
number of people you were sending money
to in that first
uh gosh i must have spent a whopping
five thousand dollars so
still forget how much money we uh i mean
it's still legit especially
uh after it translates to um kenya i
mean like you know it'd be enormously
impactful i'm sure when people
first started getting money they were
freaking out oh yeah
um and that's what we did then we tried
to experiment with the operations
right say okay can i just hire the
village elder and ask him
to pick the people and give it out well
that probably didn't work so well
i don't have problems he picks his
friends and family yeah that one was
obvious in retrospect
can we pay in pace agents because
they're already going around on
motorbikes delivering sim cards and
things can they be part of this
well that worked okay and how do you
start to put the checks and balances in
place
to build out this robust cash
distribution infrastructure
and that's what we did and we've evolved
a lot a decade later
well so then uh then who who's the first
investor or supporter that recognizes
that what you're doing is profound and
says you know what
instead of you just doing bake sales and
like getting a few hundred bucks from
your friends we're gonna give like you
know
you this like like who is the the first
to figure it out
yeah so it was a a friend named vivek
who i have to give credit for he uh
he had his first finance job and said
this is great
like i want to fund some of this and
gave us a bit more
uh money and said see if we can grow
this
we then launched a research project
because we were academics and
before scaling anything we wanted to
know that exactly what we were doing
also worked yes we had evidence on cash
but we did not yet have evidence on us
and we wanted to build that so we did
our first research project use some
research funds for
two two too much research man should
have yeah
been like we know this works like god's
blazing
yeah i i hear you with the money no i'm
just kidding well it helped it helped
and it helped because there are a lot of
people that wanted to engage and that's
what was nice
so the first big check that we got um
well there are two one was unorthodox
philanthropy and
uh the lampert family which is an
incredible story
yes they he said you know we had a big
stack of applications
it's one of these programs where you
submit a page or two wow
that works it was it was a few thousand
dollars at the time
oh wow and he'll tell the story he
remembers someone pulling out the stack
and saying
this is the worst application i've ever
seen this goes against
everything we do in the sector and we
cannot fund this
mark being mark said what is that one
that one was give directly
so that was the next step and then once
we had run the research we had gone over
to see google.org
and they said at some level
we don't care what you're doing let's
show me the data let's engage at the
data level
and to their credit they engage in the
data and they said this is really good
and then challenges us to think bigger i
remember going in i forget what we were
asking maybe it was hundred thousand two
hundred thousand dollars at two hundred
thousand dollars
what if we gave you a few million
dollars could you open a new country
could you expand this
because this could be a billion dollars
two billion dollars to the poor
this could be billions of dollars to the
poor so at what point did you realize
that
this was going to be your life uh you
know like you're in grad school
you're doing this at what point did you
say you know what where where like this
organization
is uh going to be my uh contribution my
life's work
and that you you're going to be the ceo
oh gosh i think i knew i wanted to work
on poverty
forever i think it's a very practical
pro
it's tractable we can solve it and it's
important
um on the ladder gosh it implies that i
planned that long
but so so what i'm just asking is like
you're a grad student
and then like uh oh i had no we had we
didn't even know if it was going to be
an org
we all four of us paul jeremy rowett and
i all took turns running it
uh at the beginning that well that's one
of my questions is like you know you
have a group of people around it and
then
uh like you know there there are other
things one could do professionally with
one's
degree and whatnot oh yeah well this was
on this side
um yeah there's a side project and it
started to grow and grow and the thing
that we were skeptical about was whether
people would give this way
there were so many people that said no
one's going to give this way
like why would you give us cash when you
can give us microfinance and get your
money back
why would you give us cash when it's
less appealing than giving a sheep or a
goat
so we didn't know so we did it for years
on this side
everyone took turns um and then it
started to grow little by little
and i forget exactly or maybe it's
2011-12 it's like oh actually
we should really be doing this and
trying to grow it so fat
and again you you were one of my
inspirations
uh when i was looking at this for me i
discovered universal basic income
uh 2013-14
uh from from uh futurist writings
yeah uh martin ford and the like um and
uh all of the things i'd seen about the
future of work
ended up being like and at some point
we're probably gonna need something like
universal basic income
and i was like yeah that seems right
that seems right um but the the book
that pushed me over the edge was
andy stern's book in 2015 raising the
floor where the labor guy
came out and said yeah we're going to
need we're going to need universal
basically
i was like okay the techies saying that
technology is going to displace workers
you you can understand why they would
naturally think that but then the labor
guy saying that technology is going to
displace workers
um and so when i started looking into it
uh in earnest
uh you you were one of the people that i
turned to
to demonstrate that it works in a range
of contexts most of give directly's work
at that point and still is in in the
developing world
and you and i work together on some ways
to get people
money during the pandemic uh which was
exciting
if you fast forward to today uh like how
many people are receiving money
through give directly and what kind of
sums have you
actually transferred because i know it's
really significant at this point you
know i haven't talked to you in a number
of months so like the numbers have
probably like gone up even since last
time i spoke to you yeah so
it's about a million people uh we've
raised about a little bit over 700
million at this point 700 million
dollars
um we have a long ways to go there is a
lot of poverty
left in the world so extreme poverty is
a dollar ninety a day
and people aren't at zero let's say
they're at a dollar so another dollar a
day
gets them across the poverty line yeah
350 bucks a a year
get someone out of extreme global
property yeah they used to say
it's a cup of coffee a day but it's not
even it's a sip
and that's an amazing opportunity don't
give from guilt
give because for a dollar a day
you can help another human being cross
the poverty line and that's pretty
powerful
and this is a finite problem right
there's 750 million or so people in
extreme poverty
let's just count down to zero together
we have the money right you look at some
numbers they looked at
billionaires own about 10 trillion
dollars of assets
wealth-wise globally let's say they're
getting about a 10
return it's one trillion dollars a year
people will estimate the poverty gap at
a bit less than 100 billion
even if you said we're going to spend
400 billion the returns alone
on that could do it u.s europe gdp is
about 40 trillion dollars
if everyone there gave one percent we
could do it
why aren't we doing it why aren't we
just coming indeed why
why why are we not so you're uh so
you've now
helped a million people around the world
and how many different countries
uh about 11. about 11. uh
and everywhere you go uh there are
billboards with your face on it
and thankful
parents stop them we try not to put this
face on any billboards oh see
again michael this this is where you're
going wrong you have to influence these
elections
michael fay should be president of these
11 countries simultaneously
um so we do not want that to be the case
i don't i don't want that to be the case
either no i i'm kidding like
you know it's one of the fun things
about your work is that
uh more people should know who you are
in my view more people should know about
give directly everyone who supports me
should
love give directly and it's like such a
a tremendous way to have an impact and
help another human being uh really
effectively and inexpensively
and and all of the ways that people are
concerned it's like oh if i give money
to this organization where does the
money go is it like you just skip all
that stuff it just goes like directly in
the hands of someone yeah
it's going to elevate and just two
things on that one
we should be making the pushes for
donors
governments to be doing more
unconditional cash there's no question
we should do that
and right now the money that you're
transferring on a regular basis
um is that coming from uh philanthropist
primarily it's both
it's both so we are doing more work with
governments
than any ever before and we're doing
some of our coolest work with government
so to give you one example
yes um we are working with the
government of togo
during covet many governments started
cash programs i think it's over
150 cash programs started during covet
but they were harder because you
couldn't go door-to-door and enroll
people so you had to find ways to reach
even more people remotely without going
door-to-door so what do you do
so along with the government of togo
we worked on a program to distribute
what wound up being
coveted relief payments to over half a
million people
and the entire thing took less than two
weeks wow
and then government-led how do you do
that how do you reach half a million
people
in two weeks well what we did was we
used data
and we combined it with some algorithms
where you can actually look at
individual
people's individual data if they consent
right so that's
really important part of this they
should definitely consent is critical
but togo happens to be a country where
everybody has a cell phone
you can look at the data from that to
identify who is poor or not
and it's machine learning so you can't
articulate exactly what it is but you
get a sense if someone's calling europe
for two hours a day they're probably not
the poorest of the poor
right if they're receiving thousands of
dollars of remittances they're probably
not the poorest of the poor
um they would get a text say or they'd
hear a radio ad saying we're doing this
national program if you want to enroll
type three digits to forget the digits
eight four four pound
um we'll send you a text we'll call we
have two few questions for you
click yes money shows up on your phone
that's it
that's the complexity of it you can
reach more people
more efficiently more quickly remotely
than ever before
so we're working on this with a number
of other countries but what's possible
with this kind of methodology is wild so
imagine there's the nepalese earthquake
so what's the normal response we all
scramble what are we going to do
it might take weeks months to respond
imagine if i could tell you who was
located near the earthquake
how poor they were and within minutes of
the earthquake
put money onto their phones i'm going to
describe
a a very different um set of experiences
also during the pandemic so
early march uh i i'd started an
organization
humanity forward um kovid shutting
everything down
and so we decide to give
a million dollars to a thousand um
struggling families in the bronx
as quickly as possible with the thought
being that
it would help them be able to adhere to
public health guidelines and would also
be an emblem for what our government
should be doing
at scale yeah and uh and so
we think okay how can you identify a
thousand poor families in the bronx as
quickly as possible
um so the first thing i did was i called
um
jp morgan chase and citibank and said
look
you have data on your customers you can
tell
who's poor who's struggling who a
thousand dollars make a massive
difference to
we'd like you to just identify a
thousand customers then we'll send them
each
a thousand dollars uh and you can you're
smiling so you probably know what
happens next
[Laughter]
um so uh they give us the runaround and
then they say
uh we can't do that and they they cite
you know
privacy concerns and i was like you do
realize we're just actually trying to
give your customers a thousand bucks
and you know you can explain however you
want like doesn't matter
and they're like no can't do it so then
we ask them
all right if you can't do that how about
you just give us
debit cards or cash cards of um
any increment you want in a million
dollars uh you know you can make it a
hundred make it 250 like whatever you
want
and they're like no can't do that um and
so
happily not not you know being um you
know like
uh uh get [ __ ] done type
uh i had a parallel track going that
whole time which was trying to find
organizational partners uh who could
fill
this need and so we found one
neighborhood trust that works with
struggling families uh in the bronx and
other parts of new york city and so they
said we can identify a thousand
families so we went through them um
they also had a personal financial
counseling session with each recipient
so
you know it worked out great um but
uh you know that like it it's it was
discouraging
because you'd think that uh folks who
had the data on who's poor would be
interested
in maybe doing something about that uh
but we reached the right people but the
moral of the story was
um that it was harder than it should
have been well that story highlights so
many of the challenges right
and i'm writing a piece now on you look
at a lot of our government programs
they're not
hitting the poorest of the poor for
various reasons or
operational complexities and issues or
delaying things even the
the cash relief checks that have gone
out and various people are writing
yeah it's it's gone to people who file
tax returns
you know they don't even interact with
it so then when you're trying to help
them
you know you miss them and that's tragic
and it's not the point
um but the the reason that's happening
is that of course our tax return pipes
were not intended for this purpose
and when i had a conversation with ben
bernanke about this
uh he said well you could have a fed
account for
every person in the united states um
mapped to
the social security number um and then
just put money in their account
like it doesn't actually have to be
through the irs
it shouldn't be through the irs but just
the irs is the only set of pipes that we
have
that could fill this need so we just
keep on leaning into it
because it works better than anything
else that we have even though you know
togo set up something that reached the
truly indigent uh effectively yeah
the operations matter and we need to
invest in them to get better it sounds
so trivial to say
but it's so often forgotten and you look
and we've made progress
in this country but you look back at the
um the old kind of
uh checks that got sent in the mail and
we couldn't print enough checks and get
them in the mail quickly enough to get
to people like that was actually the
bottleneck
like surely we can do better than that
as a usa
2020 and 2021 like not enough ink in the
printer
reminds me i got delayed on a slide i
forget which country i was in i think it
was burundi
and it was uh the printer is out of ink
so we can't print the flight list
so we're gonna have to wait for a few
hours until we can get in a new printer
card oh gosh
you now run one of the most successful
nonprofits
uh really anywhere um and one of the
questions that nonprofit leaders get all
the time is like you know
uh why don't you scale one of my least
favorite
um and and uh as someone who's run a
nonprofit like the answer is well
if you gave us money to scale we could
scale it's exactly right
i mean give directly last year i think
we raised about 300 million
or so which makes us one of the fastest
if not the fastest over the last
20 years certainly in the international
context 300 million
is not a lot of money but if you zoom
out for a second
it's a broader theme which is
non-profits aren't really scaling
at the levels that you would see in the
for-profit space
and you're not seeing as much change in
the market as you do in the for-profit
space
so here's one fact it's probably two
years out of date
but i think the point remains so if you
look at the five largest
companies in the u.s uh see if i get
this right apple
microsoft google amazon
facebook the oldest one of those is
microsoft so i think that's about 45
years old or so
this one so pretty new so a lot of
change on that dimension if you look at
the five largest
non-profits in the us i think the
youngest
is about 100 years old so there's just
not a lot of change in the space
which makes you ask why and i think
there's one fundamental difference
between non-profits and for-profits
for profits there's a feedback mechanism
with the customer
if you don't like the iphone you bought
don't buy an iphone next year
buy a different phone and because of
that apple needs to innovate
and make sure you want to buy an iphone
next year
in philanthropy if the recipient doesn't
like what i gave them
if i gave you a sheep but you didn't
have any use for a sheep
you're gonna fire me no are you going to
not buy a sheep from me nobody's going
to buy this you're just going to take a
picture of me smiling next to the sheep
and then you're going to send it to the
funders being like look at how happy he
is with the sheep
get us more money so we can give them
two sheeps next year
that is the mechanism and that has
incentives baked in that we need to
figure out how to solve because what
that means is that the
customer in my view the recipient the
person that you really should care about
doesn't have a voice in what they get
and the donor
who's paying has all the voice
so so much about what cash is is putting
that voice
or giving that voice back to the
recipient
let's let them choose don't trust cash
trust recipients
trust people trust people trust humans
trust them to be able to solve their own
problems and make their own decisions
as opposed to treating them like infants
and saying like you know what you need a
sheep
of course and it's not even no one's
perfect
i'm not saying trust them perfectly but
trust them more than trusting me to pick
the right thing for them
right we're not here to say anyone's a
hundred percent rational
all i'm saying is that someone living
they've got a better village
that's a better shot than i do
you know thousands of miles away it's
like i know what i know what you need
uh so you're in the midst of this
incredible 12-year trial in kenya i
think you're in year
five or something along those lines and
there's actually a documentary being
shot
on the results of that trial i can't
wait to see it it's called
drumroll free money the documentary is
coming out
next year i imagine that uh
you're pumped to have the results of
that trial out because i think it's like
the longest term trial that anyone's
ever seen
yeah that's right so this will be 12
years of cash to people
and why i think that's interesting so
universal basic income we've talked
about this a lot
there are three parts it's universal so
it's to everybody
it's basic it's not a lot of money it's
just enough to meet your basic needs
and it's an income so it's not a
one-time transfer it's over long term
so that combination hasn't really been
evaluated
we do parts of it so we'll do the
universal part or we'll do
but the combination hasn't really been
tested
why is that interesting it's the first
question that you get when you tell
people
we're giving people money for a long
time is well won't they become dependent
won't they stop working and we got this
a lot
early days give directly and one of the
responses to it was
give directly doesn't give people money
over a long period we give people money
once
so we give you money to invest and
that's it you will not get more money
you can't be dependent if you're not
getting more now we're testing what this
looks like over a long period of time
and that's what i think makes this
exciting and we've had some early
results
we released results during covid
and that was interesting for a second
reason so you might say great we know
cash works in
most contexts we've seen but how does it
work during a pandemic when markets are
shut
right if i give you money but if you
can't buy anything what's the point
so a lot of questions about whether cash
would still be effective during
pandemic and the answer was yes you saw
the same results you saw impacts on
mental well-being you saw impacts on
consumption
you saw a lot of the same things you saw
elsewhere
so people were concerned about getting
money consistently and
you know i'm sure your data will bear
this out um that it still
does not mitigate uh the impulse to work
uh and and that people are as productive
or
in many cases more productive you know
talk about making people dependent
it actually is more likely to make them
less dependent or more more independent
um but i can't wait for your data to
bear that out
um there are a number of things that i
got when i was running for president
uh the biggest question i always got was
where do we get the money yeah um and
the argument i always had was like oh we
have the money
[Laughter]
and now we've definitely seen that um
through the relief bills that have been
put out
um and one of the things that i'm
concerned about right now
is that there's inflation in the u.s
economy and i think the
um the unsophisticated might look at and
say oh it's because we've
uh delivered these relief bills and that
we we've printed this new money it's
like no no that's not why
there's inflation in the u.s economy
right now it's because the supply chain
um has been broken to the point where
they can't fire it up as easily and so
there are a lot a lot of costs that are
baked in um so when you were initiating
this long-term trial
um you got some resistance uh on this
uh this front um did you like how did
you overcome it
or like or was it something like hey
let's just see what happens
the latter i think we know now enough
about cash that people believe
the impacts will be positive i think you
have this
new question of dependency um and the
results are the opposite which is
because you have the comfort
and freedom to invest right because now
i know my basic needs can be met
i can take more risks i can try that
business that i've always wanted to try
not all are going to work but at least
you have the freedom to try
you brought up an important point which
is inflation right this is
this is one of the biggest questions you
get on cash if you drop cash in a region
why won't prices just all come up
essentially negating any gains that you
might see
and that's a very reasonable question
and one that you would need to test
to know the answer which is what happens
do people actually
do better or do prices just go up
and the answer has been pretty clear in
the literature so
there's a recent study that we put out
um
called the general equilibrium project
because it was meant to look at the
equilibrium impacts of cash
and they estimated the impacts on
inflation and they were very very small
precisely estimated small but what you
did see was businesses becoming more
productive
and you ask how can a business become
more productive
and i'll give you this kind of
stereotypical example
or the quintessential example from that
paper which is imagine
you cut hair um so you have to go to
your store in the morning you go at 8am
you stayed at 5pm
now if people aren't coming in if one
person comes in you've still worked
a 10-hour day right you still had to be
in the shop only one person comes in you
can't
say i'm going to be a half a person of
labor today now five people come in
that's just more productivity for you
you're actually working the same amount
of time
but producing more in the economy and
that's the sort of impact you saw
and the multiplier they estimate a
multiplier so for every dollar of cash
yeah how much more you see it is about
2.6 which is consistent with the other
literature
yeah i've seen 2.8 someplace else so
look uh it's pretty consistent i'll take
the 0.2
yeah i know it's like you can say 2.5 to
3.
uh so you you've also started to try and
solve some for-profit problems through
tap tap send
um people are getting gouged on
remittances uh
and it sounds like you're finding a way
to allow people to transfer money to
their
family members um more cheaply and
effectively
cheaper faster more reliably that's the
customer experience that we're going for
and payments is a fascinating space
right because
payments conceptually you think of it
going directly from point a to point b
but that's not the way it works it stops
at seven different places
with delays and costs in the system so
what we are trying to do
is a lot of the hard work on the ground
uh the work in abhijan the work in
nairobi um
to figure out what is the cheapest
best path for these remittances uh
i mean i've seen this where if i venmo
my friend um
it's frictionless and you know there's
not much in the way of
fees attached but if someone's trying to
send
their family members money in
south america or whatnot they're getting
gouged and like there's this giant
industry
that's doing the gouging and it's really
unfair
i mean it's um more expensive to be poor
uh essentially and then after you get to
a certain level then all of a sudden it
becomes frictionless and so
it seems like you're trying to reduce
the friction for the people that need
the money the most
that's right and it takes work i mean
one of the things we talk about as the
team is put the friction on us
make us go sit somewhere for six months
and do all the hard work to figure out
exactly the right path
so that we can present a frictionless
cheap experience to
our customers and it's important so
one of the motivations for taptap was
the un sustainable development goal on
remittances
so unsustainable development goals are
these ambitious global targets for the
world
um there's a lot of them one heading is
reduction of poverty one of the
sub-bullets there is bringing remittance
prices down to three percent
globally and not having any card or more
than five percent
oh even three percent sounds like a lot
like what do you what do you get it down
to
um so we're we're we're we're
we're we're we're doing better um than
three percent
and it's imagine losing five percent of
your money trying to send it to your
family
that would make me really sad but people
just do it all the time and
and you know we're just used to it yeah
we're doing better than the three
percent
um when you've been at three i'm talking
about five percent i mean that's
terrible
but it's there there is a lot of
complexity in the system
you need to work with local banks not
very complicated
these are markets that are often
overlooked and we want to invest
in the customer we view ourselves very
much as a co-op
it's like we're just going to do the
work to make it easier for everyone else
again so heroic uh so what are you most
excited about i mean
people are coming to you with all sorts
of things you're now helping
hundreds of thousands of people around
the world we have this uh
incredible 12-year long trial that that
you're getting more and more data from
oh like what what should people be
optimistic about uh
and if you do have let's say you're a
crypto person you have a bajillion extra
dollars like send it to
give directly to send to some poor
people i mean you know like it sounds
like one thing would be
what to be excited about would just be
whether or not you're getting more
funding
but what are you seeing that can give us
all some hope
i think we should look at the results
coming out of the ubi project
and have a collective we can do this
moment
so to preview we don't see dependency
people still spend the money well you
see consumption increase you see incomes
increase
for businesses what that means
is that we can end poverty very clearly
and very mechanically
and we will continue to push governments
and we should continue to push
governments to do more
but in the meantime every one of us can
do this
and i come back to that the 40 trillion
number the one percent
if we all gave one percent of our income
we can do this
why don't we have a global movement to
just get it done
like we now have the pipes and it
doesn't need to just be give directly
right this should be collected no like
it should not just be given directly um
this should be much bigger than giveaway
guys i'm about to start a competitor and
it's called
give more directly send your money to
give more directly
you think give directly is doing it
direct we're going to do it more
directly
give directly better we've got give
directly better
give directly best well the history the
funny thing about that name was we
really wanted to be give direct for a
while but then we uh
we couldn't get that domain so we had to
go grammatically correct
[Laughter]
um that's funny but yeah we have this
moment
as a community and like let's not wait
for governments to do it like go
take one person out have your friend
take one person out and let's just do it
one by one and count down to zero
we don't need to wait that's what makes
me happy that's what makes me optimistic
no i i opened up with this uh
neuroscientist who said to me that um
that
your enemy is the human mind trying to
get people to
uh adopt universal basic income because
people
reflexively and i i know this you know
this when you talk about giving people
money
uh people immediately are like oh uh
it's gonna make them lazy
uh it's gonna cause inflation yep um you
know where do we get the money like
and and there are these knee-jerk
reactions because that is the way we're
programmed
um and uh the scarcity mindset
has been probably
vital for you know x
centuries but we're at this
crucial point in human history where we
do have the resources to alleviate
poverty
around the world if we just decided to
do so we 100
have the resources to alleviate poverty
in the united states of america we just
decided to do so
uh and the major question is whether
enough people will adopt
uh a mindset of abundance in time
for us to do it and we don't have an
unlimited window
uh because eventually you wind up with
um some negative trends
climate change being chief among them um
that may make it more difficult for you
to
to to uh to uh
solve for poverty um so this was my
mission in running for president
this is your mission give directly but
it's what's interesting is like this
human mind
conversion uh it has to happen
in uh a lot of people
um to your earlier point about the fact
that there are a number of billionaires
who have the resources to be able to
solve for this it's like if you get some
of them
into it unfortunately they count for
more
that might be you know the average
person
um but this to me is the great project
of the age is to try to shift from
scarcity
uh to abundance as quickly as possible i
agree
in an environment where unfortunately
even the affluent
have felt uh scarcity in different ways
over this last period of time um and if
it's not scarcity of
material wealth uh you know that there's
like a sense of
uh isolation or
being beleaguered or intimacy
uh or whatever it is so i think covet
has made our project
simultaneously much more difficult and
easier easier because now everyone sees
the need and hopefully the
illusions of the meritocracy just seem
all the more ridiculous where it's like
oh it's your fault it's like well it
can't really be your fault
because you know the the economy got
shut down so it's clearly not your fault
um well that's been very powerful it
it doesn't allow the othering or the
blame that so often comes with poverty
oh you're poor abuse you're naive or
something
yeah okay we're all going through kobe
because there was a global pandemic
through no fault of either of ours
yeah so so so that's good uh the fact
that so many governments were pushed to
adopt cash measures
and then everyone sees how effective
they are i mean the fact that now in the
u.s
36 million families are going to get
this child tax credit of let's call it
you know
like 300 a month uh
that's going to be an incredible poverty
reducer here in the us
uh and i feel like after people
experience that then
there's no going back from it we hope i
mean you know congress can screw
anything up but
so so there there are some trends that
are very very positive
uh in terms of cash and abundance um and
then there are some trends that are more
difficult because
again i think that um that
uh it that on an individual level i
think
fewer people are feeling as optimistic
um and perhaps generous as they might
have in another
uh period yeah it can be overwhelming
right you look at all the world's
problems and it's very easy to be
overwhelmed as an individual
um but one percent
is not a lot we can do that and we can
also probably save another percent for
climate change and maybe one for
deworming and other things
but you personally don't need to solve
everything
i need to solve everything a few people
so you might solve it
no i'm not going to solve everything
either you and me
this this conversation we're not going
to leave this room until it's on
um we're going to be spending a little
bit
but that's kind of important think about
an individual level you can solve
you can take one person help maybe one
percent allows you to take 10 people out
i don't know
so let's start there and and then we can
go and we can
we we can do this together that like it
poverty
is a finite problem that we can solve
oh that's a fitting end we can do this
together michael thank you for
being uh such a role model and
inspiration
and showing people that poverty is
solvable that we can
uh we can solve for and if we all come
together and just
have the will to do so so thank you man
really appreciate it awesome thank you
thanks andrew
[Music]
you